well there are there are recipes and and
this is where i get a little i kind of
have some life hacks
because i do know there are some recipes
that
you can make for a family now you come
from a large family right there are
recipes that you can make for your
family that will hold up
right there are like things that you can
make that will last several days
you know every day doesn't have to be a
new meal
really
you can make
like recipes that are
you know resilient and they stand the
test of
time for people
um and there are a lot there's a lot of
them that fam like let's say you had a
family
let's say you you're an american family
you've got a you have a man
and you have a woman
and you have two children
okay
and you need to feed that unit
for five days
monday
through friday
no monday through friday okay
okay
monday through friday
what you could do
how much is a 50 pound bag of rice
if you got a 50
pound
bag of rice
okay
take a look at that rice it's thirty
dollars
that is a fifty pounder right there
thirty dollars yeah take a look at that
riceland
white long grain rice
fifty dollars
i'm going to show you people a little
trick
how much ragu tomato sauce
what
ragu
how much is it is my question because
it's what 30 for the rice
yeah 30. 30 for the rice i want a big
jar you go to the biggie okay that bigen
how much is that 8.5 pounds that's right
i like sauce and pounds
right because my aunt used to make this
for her children my aunt made this meal
for her children
i'm not kidding not not the one i just
like the one i like but she made this
for her children i'm gonna tell you
about a meal that you can make for your
family that will eat through the week
eat through the week from monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday
how much is that ragu 11 39. let's do
some math let me get a calculator yeah
i'd like you to because we're we're
putting together a meal that eats
through the week it's what you need to
do to survive these times
and i am a little bit of a gourmand i
can tell you exactly
what to do
to make it special okay
so right now 41 we have what we've got
eight pounds of
tomato sauce ragu yes and we have 50
pounds of white rice
[Music]
okay
ingredient number three american cheese
how much can you get american cheese for
i'm talking about a block okay a block
go to deets and watson right there this
one right here
yeah deets and watch no not white
american yellow i like the color okay so
that's gonna be same price same price
what do we got how much uh we got uh
half a pound for four bucks
so
two pounds is how much
uh that would be 32 ounces uh
uh
16 right i'm sorry my math is i'm like
[ __ ] but
16 for cheese add that to the 41. okay
and i may do that i may make this on the
show
to show you how to do it
here's what you're gonna do you're gonna
get a big pot
and you're gonna boil the white rice
okay okay
when the rice is not all of it not all
of it okay
you don't splooge all over the woman
before she's pleasured
you take a little bit of the rice
that you need however whatever will fill
your family you know how many cups of
rice per person two cups three cups uh
about two cups about two cups of rice
per
per person more than a serving there
yeah more than a shirt but you give them
a lot it's because this is what they're
eating this is there there's nothing
else so you give them a good amount and
you take
you take the ragu tomato sauce you mix
it up with the rice
okay
and you could do the ragu with the
vegetables in it because then it is some
vegetables and you mix it with the rice
you melt you go to the microwave
after you've done that and you melt
two slices of american cheese or you
could shred it
on top
of
the white rice and the ragu tomato sauce
and you mix it up you mix up the cheese
and the sauce and the rice
and then you feed
your family
well why are you saying no
why are you saying no
you privileged
prick
what's what are you saying no for
it's like dog food no it's not it's not
like dog food at all it's people need to
live
you sick [ __ ]
people need to live
it's not dog food
it's white rice with ragu tomato sauce
and then melted american cheese through
it
and it gives you enough you can survive
for a week
with how much money how much did that
all cost uh that was
let's see here
so that was
57.38 divided by five okay divided by
five
uh
11.47 for 11.47
you can feed your entire family for the
week
is that a problem
now i'm gonna do school lunch okay i
just gave you dinner okay breakfast
breakfast is easy right
breakfast you could just buy big tubs of
oatmeal oh yeah yeah right easy easy
i'm not even dignifying breakfast with
an ant you can get free breakfast half
the time okay you go pretend you work at
a company and get their breakfast you
can get free breakfast
if you want to get it it's easy to get
free breakfast go attend a seminar
they'll give you a free breakfast now
and you don't need breakfast either
for school lunch
this is a very easy thing to do
if you want to make school lunch for
your kids
okay
you get a bag of white rice
you get
ragu tomato sauce
and you get american cheese
you cook the rice
and you mix it in with the tomato sauce
and then you melt the cheese through the
rice
you get a tupperware
and you put it in it
and you send them to school with it
that is easy
so if people are complaining about
inflation and that they don't have any
money
or you could give your kids to the ant
word either way i don't care i'm just
saying it's an easy meal
it's an easy me it's not a big deal
well i'm sorry what did you eat duck a
larange every night
is that what you ate with your family
what was a meal that you people would
have i don't know like you know the
don't you eat sandwiches on like
holidays yeah turkey sandwiches
yeah about daddy what are you chicken
spaghetti yeah which is like olives and
uh is that worse than what i said
not really no no
i'm sorry is that better than what i
said like
chicken spaghetti is that a thing the
thing you described is that a real thing
or did you just make it my aunt used to
make it for her children what's it
called and one of them's a mover he's
doing fine
listen what do you mean what's it called
it's called rice
which tomato sauce and american cheese
and you would eat it
she tried to make it for me once i threw
the plate in her head
i said don't come near me
but that's what it is that's a way to
eat you you want a meal that'll eat
through the week eat through the week
what about stuffing
can't you make a big pot of stuffing for
your family
and just give them stuffing
stovetop that's pricey
yeah it's up there
it that is very expensive stovetop
stuffing
yeah here's an off-brand from you know
what my father used to make mashed
potatoes that started out as powder
oh yeah yeah that's like a divorce dad
meal you get some powdered mashed
potatoes he would take steak london
broil he'd burn it he'd put it on a
bagel
that's like a divot yeah that's right
idahoan
this is instant potatoes
this is what people in this country eat
they eat tyson
holly farms
chicken they eat instant mashed potatoes
i mean this is what people eat
and there's nothing wrong with it
this is our diet
this is our culture
yeah look at this by the way pull that
up this actually looks great tomato rice
with cheddar
and you're acting like it's a like a
problem it looks like olive garden
i'll of course he'd be lucky as hell to
be an olive garden that's what i'm
saying yeah it looks it actually doesn't
look bad you'd be lucky as hell to be in
an olive garden with the way things are
going in this country
that's the meal you make rice sauce
cheese move on
or you know those oyster rat crackers
that you get for free with the soup
yes
if you
give your kids like so for example
you can get those oyster wrap crap you
might be able to go to a restaurant if
you go to red lobster at the end of the
night you look sad
and go do you have any leftover oyster
crackers they might give you some money
also here's the other thing folks if
things are big
you know like
beg at local restaurants
and if you have cute kids send the kids
in
to like applebee's and to shift and and
tell them go listen if you turn the
waterworks on a little bit we might be
able to get something
send your chil
this is america
it's about ingenuity
it's not about
sitting on your couch and feeling sorry
for yourself it's about sending your
children in to local
theme restaurants to beg for food
that's
america it's why we fought all these
wars
if you don't have anything to eat send
your children olive garden
crying at 9 55
and ask and just say we don't have any
food
my parents are too embarrassed to ask
can you give us food
send your children
into the olive garden
five minutes before clothes
and ask for leftover food say i don't
even even if it was on someone else's
plate i don't even know obviously
they're not gonna give you food off of
someone else's plate but enhancing the
desperation will help you
i mean
or you could just sit back and take it
but if i know something about america
the greatest country on earth
land of the free
home of the brave it's that we don't
we
really
when the going gets tough the tough
send their children to in to beg for
food
so
and then you can all go home
with the food that you just got from the
cheesecake factory to give you some
leftover food maybe to give you a big
thing of mashed taters
and then you could go home and you could
watch selling sunset or one of the real
estate shows
and you can tell your children how great
it is
that we live in a country
where people pay 10 million dollars to
live in [ __ ] boxes
stacked on top of each other on top of
the uh sunset heroin strip
and you can explain that to them while
they eat their
mashed potatoes that they were given
because they cried at the cheesecake
factory
during close